بايدن يتعهد بمحاسبه المسؤولين عن انهيار
بنك السيليكون وتعزيز تنظيم ورقبه البنوك
الكبرى
اوروبا تضاعف واردات الاسلحه وبريطانيا
تستثمر ست او ست مليارات دولار في مجال
الدفاع
قبل ساعات من مناورات عسكريه امريكيه
كوريه جنوبيه واسعه النطاق
تطلق صاروخين كروز من غواصه
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
سنبدا من الولايات المتحده حيث اعلن
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن التوصل الى حل
في ازمه بنكي سلكن
في اعقاب اجتماعي وزيره الخزانه جانتيالين
ورئيس الاحتياطي الفيدرالي مع مجلس اداره
البنكين وطمان الرئيس الامريكيه المذيعين
في هذين البنكين بان ودائعهم موجوده
ويمكنهم سحبها عند الحاجه وقال بايدن ان
الحل الذي تم التوصل اليه مع مسؤولي
البنكين الذين اعلى اعلنن هي رهما
يجنب تعريض اموالدا في عيد الضرائب للخطر
والرئيس الامريكي تعهد بمحاسبه المسؤولين
عن انهيار بنك سيليكون مؤكدا التزامه ببذل
المزيد من الجهود لتنظيم ورقابه البنوك
الكبرى
قال مسؤولون امريكيون ان عملاء بنك
سيليكون فالي سيستطيعون الوصول الى
ودائعهم بدءا من اليوم الاثنين وقالت
وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه ومجلس الاحتياطي
الاتحادي والمؤسسه الاتحاديه للتامين على
الودائع في بيان ان المودعين يستطيعون
الوصول الى كل اموالهم بدلا من اليوم
الاثنين وانا دافعي الضرائب لن يتحملوا اي
خسائر لها علاقه بالقرار المرتبط ببنك
صندوق النقد الدولي اكد انه يراقب الاثار
المحتمله على الاستقرار المالي بسبب
انهيار بنك سيليكون بالي معبرا عن ثقته
تتخذ الاجراءات الملائمه وقال متحدث باسم
صندوق النقد الدولي ان الصندوق يراقب
التطورات والاثار المحتمله مشيرا الى ان
هناك ثقه بتعامل واشنطن مع الازمه كونها
تتخذ الخطوه المناسبه لمعالجه الوضع
اللي صار مع بنك سيليكون فالي انه فعليا
خلال يومين انفتحت ابواب الجحيم والسهم
هبط من مستويات عاليه جدا 268 دولار الى
مستويات الواحد واربعين شفنا تخوف خلع
كبير بانيك الكل كان يبادر يذهب الى البنك
من اجل السحوبات وسحب اموالهم تم سحب
اجمالي 42 مليار دولار خلال يومين بس عشان
هذا الرقم للمجتمع يسمعوا خلال
اما في بريطانيا فقال وزير الماليه
لن يشكل خطرا على نظام الماليه في البلاد
لكنه سيكون خطيرا على قطاعات اخرى
اعتقد ان اول شيء يجب قوله هو ان محافظ
بنكي انجلترا المركزي قد اوضح تماما انه
لا توجد مخاطر منهجيه على نظامنا المالي
لذلك يجب طمانه الناس على هذا الاساس ولكن
هناك خطر جسيم على تقنيتنا وقطاعات علوم
الحياه والعديد منها يتعامل مع هذا البنك
الذي لم يسمع به معظم الناس
اعلن رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه ريشيسوناك
ان المملكه المتحده
عفوا ستستثمروا 5.6 مليارات يورو اضافيه
للعامين المقبلين في قطاع الدفاع وقلب
بيان صادر عن
هدف هذا المبلغ يتمثل بتجديد مخزون ذخيره
وتعزيزه وتحديد مؤسسه طاقه نوويه
البريطانيه وتمويل المرحله التاليه من
برنامج غواصات اوكاس وبحسب البيان فان
المملكه قررت اعاده النظر في هذه المراجعه
الاستراتيجيه للرد على تهديدات جيوسياسيه
ناشئه من الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا مرورا
لما وصفته بالاكراه الاقتصادي من جانب
الصين وصولا الى زياده المنافسه بين الدول
افدى تقرير لمعهد ستوكهولم الدولي لابحاث
السلام ان واردات الاسلحه الى اوروبا
تضاعف تقريبا في عام 2022
مدفوعه بعمليات تسليم ضخمه الى اوكرانيا
وبفعل تسارع الانفاق العسكري من جانب دول
اوروبيه عده مثل بولندا والنرويج وقد
ازدادت نسبه واردات الاسلحه الى 93% على
مدار عام واحد واشار تقرير الى ان الحرب
في اوكرانيا تسببت في زياده كبيره في
الطلب على الاسلحه في اوروبا لتتحول
اوكرانيا وبشكل سريع في عام 2022 الى
ثالثه اكبر وجهه للاسلحه في العالم كنتيجه
مباشره للمساعدات الغربيه وقد استحوذت
اوكرانيا وحدها او وحدها على
31% من عمليات نقل الاسلحه الى اوروبا
وعلى 8% من اجمالي عمليات تسليم العالميه
وفقا لبيانات التقرير
غواصات نوويه ستجوب المحيط الهادئ قريبا
على اثر صفقه ثلاثيه بين كل من استراليا
من طرف وبريطانيا والولايات المتحده من
طرف اخر لتثير حفيظه الصين التي تعتبر
المشروع خطرا عليها
صفقه ثلاثيه ستغير الوجود العسكريه في
منطقه المحيط الهادئ وتجلب اليها غواصات
بالدفع النووي
الاتفاق الثلاثي بين كل من استراليا
والولايات المتحده وبريطانيا سيؤمن
لكامبيرا خمس غواصات نوويه خلال العقد
القادم من طراز يو اس اس فرجينيا
والغواصات البريطانيه الهجوميه السود وما
يميزها هو صعوبه الرصدها وامكانيه السفر
لمسافات طويله بالاضافه لقدرتها على حمل
الصواريخ عابره للقارات
الصفقه جزء من تحالف اوكوس الثلاثي الهادي
الى تشارك التكنولوجيا العسكريه والذكاء
الاصطناعي الذي يضم الدول السابقه تحالف
جاء عام 2021 كانت فعلا على نشاط الصين
المتنامي في المحيطين الهندي والهادئ
اتفاقيه اوكوس تدور حول المستقبل كما انها
تطفي طابعا رسميا للقيم والمصالح المشتركه
لدولنا الثلاث
اعتبرت المشروع الجديد خطيرا هادفا الى
حصارها رد فعل مشابه لاعلان تحالف اوكوس
عندما ادانت الخارجيه الصينيه التصدير
التكنولوجيا النوويه الامريكيه الا ان
كبرى دول اسيا كانت قد اعلنت عن زياده
بنسبه
7.2% من ميزانيتها الدفاعيه لعام 2023
لتكون اكبر زياده منذ العام 2019
اذا عمر العربيه
مرحله جديده تدخلها معركه بخمه المستمره
منذ قرابه ثمانيه شهور مع اعلان الدفاع
الروسيه سيطرتها على 50% من المدينه حيث
كانت ولا تزال باخموت نقطه محوريه في
القتال العنيف بين الجيش الاوكراني
والقوات المواليه لروسيا تحديدا
المعارك في بخموت تاخذ منحا جديدا باعلان
فاجنر سيطرتها على جنوب المدينه رغم شح
الذخيره الذي بات مشكلا يؤرق الطرفين
المقاومين الاوكران والقوات المواليه
لروسيا وفقا لتقرير صادر عن صحيفه نيوزويك
قوه ستسعى في المرحله المقبله الى اعتماد
استراتيجيه جديده تساعد في تحقيق مكاسب
اكبر وتجنب خسائر محتمله حيث كشفين انه
سيتم اصلاح المجموعه واعاده هيكلتها
وتصميمها بشكل يضمن تحولها الى منظمه
عسكريه موازيه من النخبه للجيولوجيه خطوه
ستضمن دورا مهما لقوات فاجنر في اوكرانيا
التي ستكون مرهونه بموجه جديده من التجنيد
عبر روسيا التي ستتبع لانشاء جيش هندي
مكون ايدولوجي يركز بشكل خاص على تجنيد
المقاتلين الشباب وفق مراقبين فان هذه
الخطوه يمكن ان تزيد فجوه التوتر بين
الكريملين وقائد فاجنر الذي يوصل انتقاد
موسكو التي تسعى في كل مره لابطاء المكاسب
العسكريه خصوصا في بخموت التي باتت نقطه
محوريه في القتال حيث ان قوه فاغنر اسهمت
في السيطره على حوالي 50% من المدينه بعد
معارك قويه خاضها الجيش الروسي جنبا الى
جنب مع مجندي مجموعه فاجنر للسيطره على
المنطقه
قالت الخارجيه الايرانيه ان نفيا واشنطن
توصل لاتفاق حول السجناء امر مثير
للاستغراب وذلك بعد ان وصف البيت الابيض
تقارير التي تتحدث عن صفقه للافراج عن
السجناء بالكاذبه وكان وزير خارجيات ايران
تحدث عن التواصل الاتفاق المبدئي مع
واشنطن بشان الافراج عن سجناء
[موسيقى]
نواصل تبادل الرسائل مع الجانب الامريكي
فيما يتعلق فقط بتخفيف العقوبات فيما
يتعلق بتبادل الاسرى الحاليين بين ايران
والولايات المتحده فقد توصلنا خلال الايام
الماضيه الى اتفاق اذا صارت الامور على ما
يرام في الجانب الامريكي اعتقد اننا سنشهد
تبادل الاسرى في المستقبل القريب
افدى مراسل العربيه بعوده الهدوء الى
منطقه تاجوراء شرق العاصمه طرابلس بعد ان
شهدت اشتباكات ادت الى مقتل شخصين واصابه
سبعه اخرين في اشتباكات وذلك بين كتبتين
مسلحتين تعرفان برحبه الدروع واسود تاجورا
وقال المتحدث باسم جهاز الطوارئ ان العمل
جاري على توفير ممر امن لاخراج المرضى
العالقين والعائلات من منطقه الاشتباكات
في ليبيا حيث قال
المبعوث الامريكي الخاص لليبيا انه يتطلع
الى استمرار المشاورات بشان الوضع في
ليبيا مشيرا الى مناقشه رؤيه المبعوث
الاممي عبد الله باتيلي حول عمليه تشمل
الجهات الفاعله والمؤسسات الليبيه
الرئيسيه مضيفا انه من الممكن وضعه خارطه
واضحه بحلول منتصف يونيو المقبل لاجراء
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والتشريعيه قبل نهايه
العام في ليبيا بما يحفز تنظيما جديدا
للانتخابات وايجاد حل سياسيا دائم
نشرتنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد قليل
وزير التعليم العالي في حكومه طالبان يهدد
كلا من او كل من يخالف الحكومه بالقتل
اهلا بكم من جديد قال وزير التعليم العالي
بحكومه طالبان ندى محمد نديم انه يجب قتل
كل من يخالف الحكومه واضاف في التصريحات
التي لقت سخطا كبيرا من شخصيات داخل
الحركه اضاف ان من يزعزع النظام بالنطق او
القلم او الافعال يجب قتله
[موسيقى]
كل من يسعى لزعزعه استقرار النظام ان كان
بالنطق او القلم او الافعال فان جميع
هؤلاء يعتبرون من البغات ويجب قتلهم
اشارت تقديرات نشرت في تقرير لمجلس الامن
الدولي ان تنظيم في العراق لا يزال يحتفظ
بنحو 400 الى 500 مقاتل نشط في حين اعلن
العراق الانتصار على التنظيم المتشدد في
2017 لا يزال عناصره ينشطون في مناطق
ريفيه ونائيه في البلاد
ويشنون هجمات متفرقه على القوات الامنيه
والمدنيين
[موسيقى]
مشهد بات يتكرر يوميا تقريبا في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه حداد واضرار يشل الحركه
التجاريه في المدن الفلسطينيه عقب مقتل
فلسطينيين فقط قتل منذ بدايه العام الحالي
برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي اكثر من ثمانين
فلسطينيه
من مدينه نابلس شمال الاراضي الفلسطينيه
خالد القاسم العربي
قبل ساعات قليله من موعد بدء مناورات
عسكريه مشتركه امريكيه كوريه جنوبيه واسعه
النطاق اطلقت بيونغ يانغ صاروخاي كروز من
غواصه وقد افادت وكاله الانباء الكوريه
الشماليه ان عمليه اطلاق الصاروخين تمت من
قباله سواحل مدينه
سيمبو في شرق البلاد فيما ذكرت وكاله يون
هاب الكوريه الجنوبيه بان الجيش الكوري
رصدا عمليه اطلاق صاروخ واحد غير محدد
بينما تلاحقه اتهامات بالتجشؤ بالتجسس من
دول الغربيه يواجه تطبيق تيك توك تلك
الاتهامات باطلاق خدمات جديده منها
والذي اثار جدلا وصفه خبراء تجميل بهجمه
لاسطوره الجمل المثالي
بينما تلاحقه اتهامات بالتجسس من دول
غربيه يواجه التطبيق الصيني تيك توك هذه
الاتهامات باطلاق خدمات جديده تحمل مزايا
مختلفه مثل فلتر بولد غلامور وخدمه سيريز
التي اتاحت لصناع المحتوى نشر مقاطع مصوره
تصل مده كل منها الى 20 دقيقه ليفتح
التطبيق الصيني ملامح منافسه شرسه امام
تطبيقات مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي الاخرى
كفيسبوك وانستجرام وحتى يوتيوب
الخدمات الجديده المعلنه لتيك توك اثارت
نوعا من التساؤلات لدى المستخدمين ازاء
قدره هذه المؤثرات الخاصه المطوره عبر
الذكاء الاصطناعي على تجميل وجوههم
لتعاود الجدل بعيدا عن تهم التجسس والحديث
عن معايير الجمال التي تسوق لها شبكات
الاجتماعي خبراء التجميل يقولون ان هذا
النوع من الفلاتر يعد احدث الهجمه لاسطوره
الجمال المثالي مما يجعل مستخدمي هذا
النوع من الفلاتر ينشطون الى استخدام
الحميات المفرطه وينقص الثقه بالنفس لديهم
تطبيق تيك توك الذي بلغ عدد مستخدمه مليار
مستخدم نشط شهريا خلال شهر سبتمبر 2021
يعتبر في الولايات المتحده تهديدا للامن
القومي من جانب مسؤولين ومحليين كثيرين
يتهمون التطبيق بنقل معلومات عن
المستخدمين لبكين وهو ما تنفيه الشركه
اشعل تغريده جاري مقدم البرامج الرياضي في
قناه بي بي سي جدلا كبيرا في بريطانيا
بعدما شبه مشروع قانون قوارب الهجره غير
القانونيه والذي اعلنت عنه وزيره الخارجيه
شبهه بقوانين المانيا النازيه بي بي سي
اوقفت عن تقديم برنامج الشهير الامر الذي
ادى لانسحاب موظفين من العمل وردود افعل
غاضبه داخل وخارج المؤسسه
تحول الجدل الحاصل حول مشروع قانون قوارب
الهجره غير النظاميه في بريطانيا من
مناقشه لمضمون القانون الى خلافات شكليه
تناول التعابير اعلاميه واسقاطات تاريخيه
فتغريده الذي يقدم برامج على قناه بي بي
سي والتي شبه فيها قانون الهجره بتلك خلال
ايام المانيا النازيه فجرت معركه كانت
تطوق اليها تيارات بريطانيا المتصارعه في
البدايه اوقف جاري عن تقديمي برنامجه
فانسحب العديد من الصحفيين من اعمالهم في
المؤسسه اشتعلت مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
ولا يبدو ان هناك تهدئه من داعمي الذين
هددوا بالانسحاب من المؤسسه بسبب ما
يقولون انه انتهاك لحريه التعبير
الاشاره الى المانيا النازيه امر حساس في
بريطانيا حيث اعتبرت وزيره الداخليه ان
لها حجه لاحد في تشبيه قراراتها بالنازيين
اعتقد انه من غير المقبول مقارنه مقاييسنا
التي تعتبر قانونيه ومناسبه ورحيمه
بالمانيا في الثلاثينيات
فيما اضطرت بي بي سي الى محاوله احتواء
قرارها
اود ان ارى يعود على الهواء على بي بي سي
لكن علينا ان ننتبه الى كيفيه الحفاظ على
التوازن بين الحياد وقدره الاشخاص الذين
يعملون لحسابهم الخاص على قول الاشياء عبر
الانترنت
مشروع قانون الهجره قرارا قاسيا لكن لم
يكن متوقعا اقحام النازيه في الجدل الحاصل
[موسيقى]
وفيما اعتبر البعض ان جاري تجاوز المقبول
في تعليقاته اعتبر اخرون ان قرار بي بي سي
قد يحد من قدره الناس على ابداء رايهم في
قرارات الحكومه من لندن عروب عبد الحق
العربيه
اعلنت السلطات بيرو حاله الطوارئ في
البلاد حيث تسبب عصار يعكوب في هطول امطار
غزيره وتدمير مئات المنازل وحدوث فيضانات
كبيره في المناطق الشماليه للبلاد ادت الى
مقتل سته اشخاص على الاقل
[موسيقى]
النشره الى العناوين
بايدن يتعهد بمحاسبه المسؤولين عن انهيار
بنك سلكن فالي وتعزيز وتعزيز وتنظيم رقابه
البنوك الكبرى
اوروبا تضاعف واردات الاسلحه وبريطانيا
تستثمر سته مليارات دولار في مجال الدفاع
وقبل ساعه من مناورات عسكريه امريكيه
جنوبيه واسعه النطاق
تطلب صاروخين كروز من غواصه تطلق عفوا
اشكركم حسن المتابعه مشاهدينا والقاكم بعد
دقائق معدودات في نشره اخرى الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]